otro bombardeo ruso sobre gersón desde
La retirada de las tropas del kremlin de
la segunda ciudad más importante de
Ucrania
Moscú ha aumentado los ataques sobre la
urbe todas las ventanas volaron me senté
en la cama la onda expansiva me tiró
hacia atrás miles de personas han
abandonado La ciudad sin embargo hay
quienes ven razones inevitables para
quedarse total si alguien nos acusa de
que estemos aquí y no nos vamos no hay
dinero para irse toda mi familia está
aquí los miembros de mi familia están
enterados aquí
me voy de aquí Volveré o no el destino
lo dirá
por su parte la región rusa de velcro
fue blanco de ataques varias casas
edificios residenciales y una planta
Avícola resultaron afectados no es la
primera vez que velcrot fronteriza con
Ucrania sufre los embates de la guerra
según el gobernador local a pesar del
accionar de las baterías antiaéreas no
se pudo evitar que varios proyectiles
impactaran en la zona el dirigente a las
fuerzas armadas ucranianas la agresión
dejó víctimas civiles esto sucede en un
contexto en el que ambos bandos
refuerzan su preparación el ministro
ruso de defensa sergey visitó sus tropas
mientras el presidente ucraniano firmó
estar listo para todos los escenarios
posibles las declaraciones las hizo en
un momento en el que Rusia y Bielorrusia
estrechan su cooperación militar para el
lunes Miss espera la visita de Putin en
medio de temores que despiertan una
nueva ofensiva invasora